dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I said it
how do people create these beautiful
computer-generated images and videos
that we see in Hollywood blockbuster
movies in the world of light simulation
programs to obtain a photorealistic
image we create a digital copy of the
scene at the camera and the light source
and simulate the paths of millions of
light rays between the camera and the
light sources this technique we like to
call path tracing and it may take
several minutes to obtain only one image
on a powerful computer however in these
simulations the rays of light are
allowed to bounce off of the surface of
objects in reality many objects are
volumes where the rays of light can
penetrate the surface and scatter around
before exiting or being absorbed
examples include not only rendering
amazingly huge smoke plumes and haze but
all kinds of translucent objects like
our skin marble wax and many others such
an extended simulation program we call
map path tracing but volumetric path
tracing and we can create even more
beautiful images with it however this
comes at a steep price
if the classical path tracing took
several minutes per image this edition
of complexity often bumps up the
execution time to several hours in order
to save time we have to realize that not
all light paths contribute equally to
our image many of them carry barely any
contributions and only a tiny tiny
fraction of these paths carry the
majority of the information that we see
in these images so what if we could
create algorithms that know exactly
where to look for this high-value light
path and systematically focus on them
this family of techniques we call
important sampling methods these help us
finding the regions where light is
concentrated if you will this piece of
work is an excellent new way of doing
important sampling for volumetric path
tracing and it works by identifying and
focusing on regions that are most likely
to scatter light and it eats the already
existing important sampling techniques
with ease now to demonstrate how simple
this technique is a few years ago during
a discussion with one of the authors
Markos Fajardo I told him that I would
implement their method in real time on
the graphical card in a smaller than
four kilobyte program so we made a bet
four kilobytes is so little we can store
only a fraction of a second of mp3 music
in it also this is an empty file
generated with Windows Word apparently
in some software systems the definition
of nothing takes several times more than
four kilobytes and after a bit of
experimentation I was quite stunned by
the results because the final result was
less than two kilobytes
even if support for some rudimentary
animations is added the whole computer
program that executes volumetric path
tracing with this equiangular important
sampling technique fits on your business
card twice absolute insanity has put a
link discussing some details in the
video description now don't be fooled by
the simplicity of the presentation here
the heart and soul of the algorithm that
created the rocket-launch seen in men in
black 3 is the same as this one due to
legal reasons it is not advisable to
show it to you in this video but this is
fortunately one more excellent reason
for you to have a look at the paper as
always the link is available in the
video description this is my favorite
kind of paper where there are remarkably
large gains to be had and it can be
easily added to pretty much any light
simulation program out there I often
like to say that the value over
complexity ratio is tending towards
infinity this work is a prime example of
that by the way Marcos and his team
recently won a technical Oscar award not
only for this but for their decades of
hard work on their Arnold renderer which
is behind many many Hollywood
productions I've put a link to their
website in the video description as well
have a look Congrats guys thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you
next time
[Music]